请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
聽到聲音加個1
黃冠
欸什麼黃冠
你的黃冠
什麼東西
來 各位晚安
各位晚安
哇 今天
300多人在線上了齁
一下要300多人在線上
喔 才剛回來而已啊
喔 才剛下飛機
欸 喔
喜歡小哥寫他媽媽互動故事
欸對阿 我
我真的覺得齁 老人家不要讓他一直在家裡
一直在家裡齁 就是
他其實他每天的環境就很單純啦
就是在家裡 房間 然後上來看我下單
然後在我旁邊念經
然後他就念他的經 然後就陪我下單這樣
那平常就比較少出門
那我是覺得他 因為現在
像我爸失智嘛我爸私自行動是也沒那麼方便所以我現在要帶他出國呢相對來講蠻困難的
不過帶我媽出國還比較簡單
比較簡單一點
好
所以呢
我覺得我媽也很辛苦啦
因為他
因為我爸脾氣沒有很好
所以
所以呢他在
他在這個
我爸失智之後
脾氣反而變好了
有些人失智之後脾氣變差
但有些人失智之後脾氣變好
那我把失智之後脾氣變好了
所以呢我們這個
就多帶他出去玩啦
多帶他出去玩
那剛好我姐呢
我姐是我的小編嘛
所以呢
他就變成他出差
出差啦
他工作的出差就是陪他老婆出國
所以這個工作應該
應該也不錯啦齁
好 來看一下
各位好 各位好
來看一下各位的留言
聲音偏小
跟著三多 財富多多
當然啦齁
這三多哥呢
這太強了齁
國具我已經賣完了啦
國具賣完了 我不曉得他
他可以強成這樣啊
這個被動元件都已經創了新高
那新高之後呢 各位我們講三多
欸那個大力光一定要買嘛
喔大力光我已經賣完了
有點可惜啊 可惜
呃小哥媽媽喜歡講話 蠻喜歡的
我的片是還沒剪啦
我之後呢這個再把它剪一剪了
再給給各位看
我之後剪 請理財寶我剪一下
好
上禮拜一次我有點沒有
噢好啦
那上個火鍋今天其實沒娃娃
那個這禮拜的火鍋
欸這禮拜去一定有娃娃
好不好
我現在夾很多娃娃就是上課送學員
然後就是不然就是吃火鍋會送
這禮拜夾蠻多娃娃
夾了九袋
九袋娃娃
機場的你看到他傻眼
這群人在幹嘛
在批發娃娃的
各位看一下
九代 九代娃娃
九代娃娃
加 媽媽身上背這一掰
背這一代呢就是那個阿嬤時代 跟少女時代有得拚啦阿嬤時代加上這一代阿嬤時代
這裡啦
我們這個九代娃娃
那因為我們都有
我們學院都有那個
就是因為我團員啦
我團員呢
我們都跟他們講說要去辦那個華航金卡
所以每個人做華航呢
都可以有兩個
兩個Coda
那這次我有做商務艙
因為
因為商務艙跟基金艙的價錢沒有差多少
這是比較晚點啦
不過那商務艙也蠻鳥的
商務艙也不大人堂
所以
這個
娃娃的扣打蠻多的
行李的扣打蠻多的
那這次
我還有三個行李沒
還要三個行李的扣打
所以
所以真的是
應該要再認真假一點
應該再認真假一點
好
跟著小哥吃穿不用走
有被海關人下來 沒有
台中全陣搬抽馬利歐香菇頭蛙
可以帶一個去
我們這香菇加蠻多的
大概已經把他的那個全部
呃只剩一個而已
剩一個
店家有很多個都被我們加完了
那我們這次去的店家非常好夾
極好夾
這是我在日本
日本看過最好夾的一個
目前為止啊
在是不是有看過最好夾一個
非常誇張
各位那個
等到片子剪出來之後呢
欸
給各位看一下
那個有多誇張
那個太誇張了齁
所以呢我強烈推薦各位齁
這個
有趣的話呢
記得去
去這個地方夾
來
我有那個啦
各位你可以追蹤我的Google帳號
我Google帳號呢有
有
就是我會打一些
呃
就是我會做一些評論啦
好 這家
這家 跟各位講 這叫旭川的站前店
旭川站前店裡面呢
裡面就有娃娃機店
那這家娃娃機店呢 是目前看過
目前全國看過呢 是最好夾的地方
最好夾
喔 那個超誇張
那個影片剪出來你就知道超誇張
誇張到我覺得那些娃娃根本都在送的
都在送的 實在太誇張了
太誇張了
所以這個
各位有機會去續穿腳
雜訪反正沒那麼好腳好腳我們那六代裡面大概有五代呢都從是啦 那那八代 欸 九代娃娃裡面呢大概有七代都在尋傳夾出來的
通常是假如遇到一家店好夾
就要拼命的夾
因為呢 這種店呢 可遇不可求
可遇不可求
那在我們夾完的隔天呢
隔天我們又去啊
隔天又去呢
前一天比較好夾娃娃的機台呢
都改台
就改台了你知道嗎
所以呢這個隔天呢反正就沒那麼好夾了
就比較好夾的
前天我們還有夾那個
像有夾那個米飛嘛
米飛啊 還有夾
欸 夾一個叫什麼
反正就是好夾的後面就不能夾了
那有幾台呢 它還沒有改到
所以呢那幾台可以夾
所以就這樣
好夾的時候你要一定要好好夾
假設你是真的很想夾的
真的很想夾的
在好夾的時候要好好夾
因為呢
這個通常你離開之後呢
他就會改台
那這次行程呢
我有
我有寫那個
呃
講一下
這是那個
我們要感謝北海盜女婿
齁北海盜女婿
齁北海盜女婿呢
各位呢
這個
欸你也可以去追一下他的頻道
齁
這個北海盜女婿呢
呃
他的影片我看很久了
齁
在這邊
喔 北海道女秀
他下一部上片就會出現我們了
因為他這次呢
也有跟我們拍影片
所以呢 下一部上
下一部片應該可能就我們
因為他有跟我要一些
夾娃的片段
那我們是跟北海道女秀包車租車的
我覺得
我覺得這次的包車齁
這包車蠻誇張的
來來來 我要PO一下這個
我們這七個人啊
我一直以為 這麼多人的行李可能載不下
結果呢 我們在機場呢 還可以
一台車齁 一台車可以放這些行李
等一下 我發文一下
一台車居然可以放這麼多
我覺得非常誇張
等一下 我弄個...發個文好了
發個文
一個Alpha車可以載這麼多
来
谢谢各位看一下那个大小
等一下
等我一下
等一下我剛剛講有人來了
好這個
我先發
先發一下這個
讓各位知道這個
這個包車
等一下
ALPHA實在太能載
載太能載
好 這二文我們這樣講
這ALPHA呢
這個
ALPHA大概就是
把這些行李全部都載上去
還載了7個人
所以你看這邊多誇張
喔 這行李都載上去還載7個人
所以這個ALPHA實在超能裝啦
超能裝
超人妝
不過但是最後一天啊
這個平常你不能這樣再啊
平常這樣再做起來有點痛苦
那最後一天反正就只有一下子而已
所以各位
你排行程的時候記得怎麼樣
你記得呢
前後呢住同一家飯店
通常你住董明燕就沒什麼問題啦
你前後都住同一家飯店
然後你在住之前你可以先寄一封信給他
通常你沒寄他也沒什麼問題
就你寄封信給他 你跟他講說 你有一些心理
部分行李 像我們這個大的行李箱呢
我們就會放在這個第一天的飯間
然後中間這個租車的時候呢 就帶小的背包這樣移動
所以中間租車其實載起來還蠻寬的
那就最後一天呢 比較緊一點
那其他事件還蠻寬的
所以這個 這樣子載也是沒問題的
這個租車公司跟我們講說
你這樣子要不要租三代車 我說不用啦
好 其實我們最後一天呢 再去
再去怎麼樣 最後一天再去
呃 再塞一下就可以了 反正我都很小
都很小
所以各位呢 這個可以
可以好好的利用
好 等一下
我再看一下留言
冬天呢 欸冬天你可以找他們家交滑去啊
可以啊
欸包車 包車是這樣 包車有分
有司機跟沒司機啊
沒司機就叫租車
有司機叫包車嘛沒司機叫租車那這個包車呢大概每個時間的行情不大一樣那我們
我們那個13個人
包車包一天10小時呢
是一萬九
也大概一萬九台幣啊
再忘記在冬天的時候會變貴
冬天的話大概會到
那個2萬多塊
那我覺得
也還不錯
這個算起來CP值滿高的
因為餘萬九你可以就排一個10小時的行程
那我們大概就是8點半出發就6點半回來
9點出發就7點回來 就這樣子
那你可以排一些要開比較遠的地方的路
自己開車就不要開那麼遠
像我們包車的話一天就開200多公里
那自己的話開個100多公里我覺得差不多了
皮克米娃娃只有一個
喔 這個fish拿走了
我們只夾到一個皮克米娃娃
皮克米娃娃非常的
蠻少見的
連那個扭蛋都很少看到
欸 這很奇怪 皮克米不是很紅嗎
就連扭蛋都很少看到
好
那 呃
甚至後面的 我們是
第一天到嘛 然後二三天是包車
然後第四天開始租車
第四天開始租車 租五天事業
那住五天事業呢
阿法一台車
反正阿法租一天大概是5000塊
大概是5000塊
應該說租24小時大概5000
租24小時5000
那阿法超級新啦
大概只有2000多公里而已
就是只開過2000多公里
他們的車子都超新的
所以
就是這樣
這個超級新的車
那裡面後面可以放很多啦
那不太多
好 那這是我們住的民宿
民宿呢 欸 民宿
裡面還蠻寬的啦
住一晚 一萬多塊
不過你假如是連住幾晚的話
會比較便宜
會到 可能就到幾千塊而已
每天 每天到幾千塊
所以你假如是一家人去的話
其實你可以住點民宿
好 那我們今天來講一下喔
這個是大概
旅遊的一些心得啦
各位有什麼旅遊心得
我們之後有影片上來再跟各位講一下
各位講一下
好 那為什麼我不用真空包呢
因為真空包有時候那個娃娃呢會變皺
我以前有用真空包裝過那娃娃有的就變皺就不喜歡怎麼怎麼不喜歡好再看喔 跟著小哥走 四關沒有走
喔
平革名在feach那邊 我有加到一個
好
欸 那我們今天這個講除言其忘記喔
一開始請各位加這幾個QR Code
上面有一個 PressPlay的九折優惠券
九折優惠券
又又再見
各位 我們最近的PressPlay
訂閱人數呢 是一直在增加
這個PressPlay這樣子
就是 他會有訂閱跟退訂
有人覺得沒有用 就會退訂嘛
最近訂閱人數一直增加
然後呢 退訂的很少
可能大家覺得有用吧
我們出門在外 我們也在做交易啊
所以呢 也沒有說出門在外就不做了
所以那個盤桿都還有
盤桿都還有
好
然後
欸各位呢
這個加一下
呃這個QR Code
粉絲團呢
跟光社團有交易的
這個知識
YouTube有教學影片
那IG呢有一些
點位圖在這裡
好
那各位請加這個
欸全證小哥討論群
密碼是4個8
密碼4個8
哇上次租北海道你去還有做全新的Yarid
他們的車子都很新
他們車子喔
這個
他們車子是
那個
反正大概都是一年內的車啦
都是一年內的車
他有跟我講一些原因啦
但是我不曉得能不能講
反正我只能告訴你
他的車子都是一年一年內的車
都很新
一年到了車子就
就會拿去賣掉
然後再變成新的車
齁
喔 賺的都能定很多年
呃 對最近大家做交易都不錯嘛
因為我們紅團的友人出門好像賺了700多萬
齁 700多萬 齁 這很猛啊
出國幾天賺700多萬
齁 尤其有一天啊 在這一天喔
在這一天呢 我會鼓勵他
趕快買啊
齁 在這一天 來來來 我們講一下這一天
齁 我們現在講一下我們出國玩呢
賺最多一檔股票
賺最多一檔股票 其實也有發文講
發文也有講
在這裡
我們有講一個這個呃...出國的看一下看一下
這裡這裡
欸?等一下
喔這裡這裡這裡有講
這感謝白道你去推薦嘛
我們去吃這雙
這超好吃的 這個海膽
這海膽呢 是現實的喔
再感受喔 這個是現實的
他們只有那個 7 8 月份
雞丹亞這邊的海膽呢
只有7 8 月份呢 可以撈
其他時間不能撈
因為假如每個時間都可以撈 早吃晚撈光
所以呢 它只有7 8 月份可以撈
所以這個是現實很美味的海膽
超好吃 超級無敵好吃
那各位呢 你可以去這一家
食堂林煌
食堂泥坊 去食堂泥坊吃
各位 記得要去啊
因為食堂泥坊這個地方呢
它有兩個景點
一個是倒五翼
一個是雞蛋俠
那這兩個呢 你都是可以走路去
就是車子停了 吃完飯
走路去倒五翼 再走路去雞蛋俠
就在隔壁而已
走個五六分鐘就到了
那不知道是不是大家歷程都漲停了
吃起來特別美味
來來
那歷程呢 是在這一天
這一天呢
這個我們在旅遊的途中
旅遊途中 我們就跟他講說
因為其實我們旅遊就會講一些股票啦
就是
就是會跟他們講說我現在要幹嘛
所以旅遊途中呢 重點要買兩個
那這兩個其實都是組織管
第一個呢 就是那個歷程
那歷程呢 我們買的位置在這裡
買的位置在這邊
在這個 前一天這個位置
欸這位置
在這附近
那為什麼要買他呢
因為立成要出關了嘛
各位看啊 立成他是典型的
處置國的型態嘛
就是這個
處置之後會跌回來
那他是籌碼比較爛的
再講一次喔 立成是籌碼比較爛的
籌碼比較爛喔
但是呢
那籌碼比較爛 但是他是怎樣
他是
被投信所害
啊這投信是誰啊
投信就是00919
那00919各位講
00919他賣的天數就8天
00919他賣8天
所以呢
他在賣下來的時候
各位你看 他現在的那個
他的賣壓呢 連外資都抵抗不了
外資雖然有買鈔 但也沒啥用
他就被他賣下來
所以歷程呢 他這跌下來有幾個原因
第一個呢 被投信所賣
那我們知道他是8天
那這個在那個
ETF吃豆腐課
各位那個 你可以去看那ETF吃豆腐課的那個影音
就有教各位呢 你怎麼樣
怎麼樣去吃這個頭性的豆腐
那吃頭性豆腐很簡單
那個賣很多 疊下來
那叫
賣盤捷徑
很簡單喔 再講一次喔
賣很多疊下來叫賣盤捷徑
那我就跟他說 這個歷程呢
賣盤捷徑一定會漲的啦
賣盤捷徑一定會漲
因為為什麼 因為他有兩個大理由
那兩大理由 第一個 其實他有三四個理由
通常我下去買的時候有四個理由
第一個是
他這個儲置股的拉回嘛
儲置股的浪子回頭
儲置股的浪子回頭第一個
然後第二個
他的缺點就是籌碼爛
籌碼爛又是投信所害 各位記得
他籌碼爛是投信所害
他不是主力在大賣 沒有 他是投信在大賣
他投信大賣投信在調整持股
那投資金為什麼要調整失股呢
因為它漲上來了 跟各位講
這01919是這樣
他呢 給各位看 01919 專門買什麼股票
01919 這是一個高股息的
高息股票呢 他要買什麼股票
他就是要買那個 殖利率高的嘛
所以呢 他要把歷程給剃除啊
因為歷程呢 漲上來了嘛
漲上來 殖利率變低了嘛
所以他要把好公司給踢掉
各位记得啊
这个高值率股票是这样
高值率的
高股息ETF就这样
他要把原本高值率
变成低值利率的
那为什么从高值率
变低值利率呢
就是因为他表现变好了
表现变好 他把踢掉
懂意思吗
你们家呢 开两家
一家卖便当 一家卖饮料
然后发现了饮料店业绩
真正日上
高股息呢 就會把它賣掉這飲料真正日上怎麼可以股價怎麼可以上來配息都一樣 股價怎麼可以上來他就把表現好的給賣掉
那歷程呢 就屬於表現好的
所以跟我講
0099沒有歷程了
0099沒有歷程
他把它賣完了
這個我覺得莫名其妙啊
你怎麼可以把表現好的賣掉了
那你的原因 理由是什麼
各位啊 表現好的理由呢就是
呃...欸...這個...
這個...表現好賣掉的理由呢
就是因為要長太多
所以...這很討厭啦
我不太喜歡這種
表現好你就要把它賣掉的這個理由
這個理由我覺得...我覺得非常不好
等一下...等一下...我...我拉一下我的留言
不然看不到
所以...那個...好的被賣掉
然後呢...後面就會怎麼樣
後面呢就會出現...不好的
那個...好的被...
喔
後面呢會出現不好的
喔 什麼叫不好的呢
來
那後來他買了誰啊
買了誰喔
買了富邦美
好 來看一下 富邦美
喔 富邦...欸 美...欸...
欸...欸...欸...
我...
我找一下
富邦美 我觀察
來來來
8454 有沒有
8454呢為什麼買
因為他變爛了
有沒有
這個富邦美被什麼
被庫朋壓著打
富邦美被庫朋壓著打
壓著打到後面
業績怎麼樣
業績就差了嘛
對不對 那個
富邦美為什麼他要買富邦美呢
因為他業績變爛
業績變爛喔 這個講是
那個業績變爛
然後怎麼樣 股價下跌
可是因為富邦美去年
去年還沒有多爛
所以呢 他配息還配得不錯
所以從那個
股價呢從180.90來看
180.90來看
他這配10塊
也還不錯 有4 5%
然後他就決定怎麼樣
那路
銀納路把富邦美買到天上去
那一買到天上去怎麼樣買完 各位有沒有看到8天 又是8天8天買完之後呢 叫做買盤捷徑買盤捷徑之後開始跌所以 副媽媽 我有空
唉 各位啊 副媽媽 我有空喔
20分鐘我還是給它空下去
我有空
空了之後呢 連續跌停2根
空完連續 應該是3根
我在這天空的 在這天空
因為我知道最後一天吧 最後一天空你
空完3根跌停
這個賺到兩根半啦 因為我在這邊空的時候已經
這疊半根了
這邊賺到兩根 兩根半
這個富邦美
富邦美這個
這個0099的買盤捷徑
所以跟各位講 你買0099你會後悔啊
為什麼 因為他去追高富邦美
有沒有 富邦美的467他買的
富邦美的467他買的喔
46G他買的喔
他把高股息買成低股息喔
超厲害的
把高股息買成低股息
為什麼
他在這裡是高股息啊
欸
200塊配10塊高股息嗎
460配10塊叫什麼高股息啊
剩2%啊
對不對
剩2%
把高股息
把它配
把它買成低股息
也在買
莫名其妙
喔
富豪美不是處理怎麼空
他是這裡啊
這邊可以空啊
這裡可以空啊
他怎麼做處理器啊
他怎麼做處理器
除期
6月11號 6月11號可以空啊
這裡啊 這天可以空啊
除期當天就可以空了 我空在這天
這天不能空 這天可以空
這天可以空
除期當天可以空
而且他是20分鐘還要入金才能空
不是個股期喔 是現股
現股喔 這個要入金才能空的喔
因為他處置啊
他20分鐘處置啊 一般人都不知道要空
因為20分鐘處置嘛
他在這天才能空
因為除息啊 除息當天
6月11號除息當天我空的
好 這個就是把
把高股息
喔 所以 哇 這個更完美了
這個高股息
各位你想想看
那個00919他買富邦買幹嘛
可以配息嘛 對不對
他買完立馬可以配息
你看一下他最近 他這邊買多少
他在這裡齁
1875張 然後買到這邊是
一萬
天啊
買了一萬兩千張
他買一萬兩千張買一萬兩千張然後去除息一之後 股價跌下來齁 那賺了配息 賠了差價
你懂嗎 那你喜歡的
九一九 就是這樣好不好
就這樣
所以我一向不喜歡買那個高股息ETF
就一堆網紅推啦 我是從來不推
齁 我從來不推高股息ETF
我覺得就是不愛 好不好
就是不愛高股息ETF
齁 你看看 他把歷程賣掉
賣掉了噴
對不對 賣掉了噴嘛
對不對 你看賣賣是噴 最近噴的嘛
對不對 今天 今天漲多少
今天漲6%
那前幾天我們買完喔 我們買在300
3001附近
買3001附近 然後呢
買完之後隔天有到多少
隔天有到363
然後又疊下來 但是今天又到346
表現不錯 我覺得後面他有機會表現蠻好的啦
齁 有機會表現蠻好的
那
這個可惜 那個副包園把他砍掉
那副包園還買了誰呢 還買了這一檔叫潤桶
你看 這也是被潤...這也是被買上去的啊
有沒有
有沒有 這也是被買上去的
齁 這潤桶高股息
那潤桶為什麼高股息呢 為什麼高股息
因為
因為他之前表現好嘛 最近表現爛嘛
齁 所以
那個之前表現好 業績好 近期營收差
喔 表現爛
表現爛之後呢 再配上之前的業績好
就會變成高股息吧
喔 表現爛再配上之前的業績好
就變高股息嘛
喔 所以買這種 欸 論紅
論紅 論紅要補啦
剩幾天
好 他就跌下來
那這個也是一樣
他也是被投信買上來
被投信買上來
然後呢
後面就跌下去
典型的買盤接近嘛
有沒有
這是不是典型的買盤接近
喔
那不只他啊
還有誰你知道嗎
還有一檔叫賣鞋子的
賣鞋子的
來1K嗎
你自己看
只是買8天
買完之後都紅K
買盤捷徑跌下來有沒有
有沒有 發現有沒有
那你說他多厲害嗎
沒有啦 錢多而已啊 那有多厲害
對不對 他們就是錢多啊
00919大家一直買嘛 錢就多嘛 就一路買上去嘛
買上去之後疊下來嘛
疊下來之後 未來會怎麼
未來會配息嘛
他配多少 配9塊
9塊高股息啊
在180的時候是高股息嘛
大概就是5%嘛
到了280的時候
變低股息了嘛 剩3%嘛 對不對
變剩3%嘛
然後他把他買 從高股息變成低股息啊
那買完之後呢 股價跌下來
買盤捷徑嘛
這典型的嘛
這就是我跟各位講的
我那ETF那個
所以有的人跟我講他喜歡買ETF
買ETF好像很厲害一樣
真的沒有很厲害啊
好不好
真的沒有很厲害
你自己看嘛
我這每年都可以舉得到例子啊
每年都可以舉得到例子
跟那個每年都有
今年也是啊 今年更誇張
來...我沒空
好像找不到券
假如有 可以空的話 爽呆
喔爽呆喔
好 所以呢
這個...
各位你喜歡高股息的喔
我是勸你直接買0050
0050通常比高股息來得好
好不好
啊或者你乾脆直接買台子期啊
買台子期啊
買台子期那個不要開槓桿
喔 自己領席啦
喔 自己領席還會比較好 好
所以這個 你看我們
即便出國在外 我們對市場的關心
對不對 我們還是看得非常的細膩 好不好
我們也沒有一直在
那個在玩不看股票 好不好 我們不是那種人
哈哈
那我們其實 我們不是出國啦 是出差 哈哈 出差
來來來
給各位看我們 我們出國都在出差啦 有沒有
出國都在打單啊
這裡啊
哇 這邊出國
打單
這在哪邊 這在星巴克
齁星巴克
冷得要死啊
那天其實外面很冷
你就穿這個哆啦A夢服裝
沒辦法 全 全雜枉就這一件
齁 就這一件東裝
不是 不是說只有這一件
只有這件東裝而已
買不到其他的
好啦欸 這個po這本3000多個讚欸欸 各位啊要穿這件衣服 那個心理素質不是一般啊
沒有被嘎過三根漲停的人是沒辦法穿的
要有被嘎過三根漲停
包括兩根跌體以上的人
才有心理素質可以穿上這一件
所以這個不是一般人可以穿的
心理素質
穿這件齒利藥很強
為什麼今天沒...今天是熱死的穿
幹嘛
這是真的冷啊
真的冷我穿這個啊
其實那天蠻冷的
那天在一去雜往晚上八度啊
怕死啊
怕得要死啊
冷得要死
這個是那個...
那個...
唐吉科的...
欸這個...
毛料超讚
而且這是一套的喔
各位這是一套的
這是...
上衣跟褲子是一套的
重點這一套才500塊
500塊台幣而已
超便宜
這套真的很好穿
好 欸 我們出國喔 你看
出國其實到任何一個地方就這樣
就下單 都要到一個
一個
就要去一個那個有訓好的地方
然後開盤收盤都這樣
開盤收盤都這樣
都要到有訓好的地方去下單
好啦好啦
這是出國的狀況
啊 這個是我出國的行程的那個
這叫AI化的
你就把 叫AI排行程
排行程之後呢 你就丟給AI化
丟給AI化 然後他就化出來給你看
還不錯啊 現在有AI 我就出國
很方便 很方便齁
做功課很方便啦 不過AI這種畫法
有些點我們沒辦法去啊
為什麼 因為其實你
你要玩到這些
這些就是
欸會有點趕
所以有時候到後面呢 有些景點就可能要刪掉一兩個
反正包車嘛 包車就沒差
包車沒差
沒有意思 這樣點 對
我們這次出國大家都賺滿多的
大家賺滿多的
你看這邊啊
神威甲上風如刀
那邊風很強啊
碧海連天擺浪高
眾人不看天涯景
天涯一景
低頭只判立成標
立成標
6月11號
下午1點34分
6月11號 有沒有
這個6月11號就是那天我們都在買都在買立成啦就是這一天都在買歷程結果隔天期貨開得快漲停
齁
小哥你那套多少歌愛
真的要買喔
原價500元位5000
不洗現在還沒洗
不洗元位5000
原價500
好啦
我們這個喔 這一天其實
那個
欸 開盤我們 開高我們就有用那個期貨必點線
開高用期貨必點線啦
就
就有賣一些期貨這樣
反正都用這個期貨跟現貨
都用期貨現貨在那邊做
都在那邊做
所以
學期貨也很重要
好
歡迎各位加這個Keymackle
Keymackle
你又...喔...我...
開團喔 有機會啦 有機會
我們現在那個每次出就十幾個人
喔 十幾個人 我又要想行程
因為行程大部分都我主導嘛
好 要想行程
還要去那個...包車租車的
不過還有那個不用開車
喔 這個我只要負責
負責那個規劃行程就好
好 咦 密碼四個八
好 密碼四個八
名牌就在文章裡 沒錯
好好追FBR 名牌就在裡面
好 咦 我今天還是處置神器齁
處置神器太好用了好不好
太好用了
太好用了 我們來看一下
處置 大家 大家賺
賺飯了 感謝處置神器
五月已實現 欸這多少錢
四萬多
哇 這邊很多處置神器齁 光潔
文心
這邊聯軍
信倉店
信倉店他又被關了
信倉店又被關了 中探針
這幾個
處置的
好
歷程 歷程有
處置成績呢 可以幫助你
找到很多交易的機會
那我們的策略非常簡單
就是浪子回頭的時候 你去看他的籌碼好不好
那其實歷程的籌碼算不好
歷程抽到算不好 但是我們還是買了 為什麼
因為 第一個他的籌碼不好 它是被投信所害
那這個投信呢 我們知道他賣完就沒了嘛他不是被阻力所害他只要被阻力所害呢就比較
我開錯簡報了
我今天沒有處置神器喔
唉呦
因為那個
我知道我知道 我解痕吧
今天沒有處置神器喔
我還以為那個簡報有欸
喔
我今天沒有處置神器
好啦 加減賣 加減賣
小編把他那個
把他打開一下
因為
我今天當中神器喔
我咧
等一下等一下
我 我要把那個弄一下
今天當中神器我
我來看一下
今天沒有處置神器
因為那個小編跟我出國了
所以這個直播銷售簡報
我還以為沒有變
回國有時差有啦 差了一小時
所以今天沒有處置神器喔
來看一下 我今天當用神器
喔這裡有啦 我今天的那個是這樣的
喔 處全行行全攻略
我今天直播快整只有當用神器喔
我沒有處置神器喔
欸
好啦 我們先把那個處置講完
來來 今天沒有處置神器
主治神器
喔 那個是之前的方案喔
沒有推 沒推算了
我們來看那個上週中獎名單
上週五
和昨天市場大跌喔
過去的我一定只剩恐慌
但因為小哥和主治神器的教學
讓我學會用科學數據取代情緒喔
在別人害怕時看見機會
勇敢於低階
布局
要加碼 可以啊 可以啊
因為有人問我有沒有那個處置神業特價
所以呢我們
你可以開就開啊
改變的不只超多嗎
跟整個投資人生啊
對啊
投資人生
我可以跟各位講
我現在決定了在我媽行動自如的時候
我打算呢這個
可以的話
當然要我家的配額
可以的話我希望怎麼樣
我希望可以每個禮拜
不是每個禮拜
每個月呢大家出國
大家出國
因為我覺得喔
他出國呢 做了很多重訓
重訓你知道嗎
他出國做很多重訓
為什麼啊 因為
他爬上爬下的啊
他爬上車
他要去拉那個桿子
要出力
下車
上下車這個過程呢
其實他都要出很多力
然後呢跟著我們一起爬坡啊幹嘛
當然是不會叫他拿重的東西啊
不過呢他只要一出去
他整個人呢
這個人都一直處於活動的狀態
然後過得又開心
看風景什麼過得很開心
所以讓肌肉不對吧
叫我媽去重訓都會
因為重訓很重要 老人家真的需要重訓
老人家真的需要
我覺得重訓對老人家非常需要
所以我未來蓋一個房子呢
我就是想在家裡放一些重訓的機器
訓練這些老人家
好啦 那個
跟我出國以後請那個火鍋店老闆
來抽個名額
讓大家跟啦
讓大家跟
好
來
感謝小賀教學與處置成績第一群大學的交流
那我們今年的獲利屢屢創新好
對不對
除此審計的第一群的500
500人都還沒退啊
都沒有人退喔
雖然還沒達到大神們的百萬
200萬甚至600萬的美女姐姐
但期待自己都追上他們
以及能夠跟上小哥的交團的大神們
這交團裡面齁真的是
賺蠻多的
哇 浪子回頭真的很好啊
最近
所以這幾檔各位看環球金
你看這浪子回頭
那個主力沒賣是噴翻了對不對
幾根又要被關了
環球金又要被關了
又準備被關了
是第一天喔大概兩天後準備被關
兩天後怎麼被關
來合金也是一樣
有沒有
浪子回頭有沒有
回檔主力沒賣就是噴啊
回檔主力沒賣就是噴
合金我到現在還有啊
還沒賣完 好不好
而且我在這邊買了300張
到這裡還沒賣完
那三八張啊 這裡還沒賣完
還有
這裡還沒賣完
這邊啊 所以這個
處置
還有你看那個被動元件的國具 你看
讓紙回頭噴翻1000 有沒有
這個 我們之前跟各位講嘛
說這個
我們希望 強烈希望被動元件趕快進處置一堆進處置它就會出現超級無敵好的買點嘛對不對 超級無敵好的買點果然沒錯啊 你看進了處置之後是不是後面噴翻
還有像這個 華新科啊
華新科有沒有
浪子回頭 噴翻 494創高
3090日電帽
浪子回頭 噴翻 309創高
還有6173 信倉電
這個浪子回頭噴翻對不對 311創高
但是我跟各位講 呵呵這個信商店又要被關了
所以信商店呢 他期待他又有浪子回頭好不好
我覺得有機會啊 因為信商店最近從來比較爛
他假如再回頭 浪子回頭 他又是一個好的買點
他又是一個好的買點嗎
黃修金如果被關回答還可以買嗎
當然可以啊
我們做法就是只要怎麼樣
只要浪子回頭籌碼不錯我們都買
只要浪子回頭籌碼不錯都買
環球金成本7.6怎麼辦
盡猜利啊好不好
賺翻了Fish賺翻了
欸喔這個有講到
欸這頓Fish請的啊
喔這頓這頓
這頓海膽餐他請的
他說他歷程賺多少
歷程多少 貪八塊板
這海膽山就是FISH出錢的
他賺一百多萬
賺一百多萬
另外一個那個
鐵板燒老闆賺了六七百萬
賺六七百萬
所以那個
跟我們出遊
這些人都會請客
因為他們在出遊過程中賺錢
都請客
出遊蠻好玩的
好就這樣
來 虛擬戰機呢
這個可能是上次抓的
上次抓的因為
小編跟我出國都沒有
沒有認真貼
來吧給各位看我近期的對帳單
近期的對帳單
我們從3月到6月
這段期間交的處置
我自己也認真的下
這下 正在期間這個處置呢
我們的獲利破了九位數
破九位數九位數啊10417221.1億啊1.1億所以這個儲置呢 有用太有用了好不好太有用了
你去看有誰對樣單這樣貼的
沒有啊 很少看過嘛 對不對
太有用了齁
那我們出遊賺期間
9號到16號賺期間
哇 賺期間我的獲利呢是400多
所以一邊出遊
那個標語道理就是誒
你們這群人好像
好像一直出去玩好像錢越玩越多的感覺
我說嗯 對啊 我們好像都這樣
就是錢越玩越多啊
因為其實出國還是蠻認真下單的
每天早上呢 都是先下完單才出去
才認真玩
先下完單
至少會找到一個訊號好的地方
訊號好的地方
好好的下單
每次都這樣 每次都會找到這個
一定認真
我覺得那個我們下單是
不會因為出國而中斷
即便我去歐洲 歐洲就痛苦了
歐洲可能要兩點出來
兩點要起來下單
那個很痛苦
半夜兩點
但在日本的話還好
日本的話就10點
這個台灣時間9點嘛
日本時間10點
我們在10點的時候
找到一個好訓鬧的地方
就可以
所以這出國呢
還是賺了400多
那這個400多是這個戶頭啦
那這個戶頭賺400多
也做了7...
這邊是7億
做了7億齁
所以呢也是繳了很多稅啊
好 繳了很多稅
好
所以這個
處置這策略真的很好啊
所以各位
等到小編弄好了
你要買
可以買
好啦
然後
然後我們今天呢要講這個
今天要講這個除全席
齁 那除全席呢
最近是這樣子齁 除全席各位你可以利用一個軟體啊
齁 利用一個軟體叫做
呃 個股世界獲利網
齁 我都會利用個股世界獲利網呢
來看一下齁
來看一下什麼 來看一下這個除全席呢
他最近的表現 跟之前的表現
齁 這個
比較一下
好
跟之前的表現比較一樣那我們來看一下最近的這個除選席的標的
最近除選席標的
好
來看一下
像今天
像明天
明天有一檔要除選席啊
叫正新
那正新呢
他前陣子的表現都不大好
那明天的表現呢
可能也不好
因為這種高股息的
高股息的
他除全息喔
他的表現喔
好像都沒有
這個都沒有表現很好
我是這麼覺得啊
高股息一定要
反正你各位記得喔
這個除全息呢
你可以做多也可以做空
但是那種高股息的
高股息的你要特別注意
不要去買他的股票參與除全息
因為高股息的股票 常常
他的那個
他的表現比較差
來 這個高股息股票
常常的表現比較差
常常那個
除期完 像正希
正希之前就表現不好 除期完
我再看一下最近除期的股票
好 我塞給你
來看一下
哎呦 我 一次的盪掉
好
真的
這個 所以 那個我們再回來
所以你要買除選期之前呢
你可能要點一下
像東元 哎呦 東元呢
之前呢 在除息當天的表現不大好
所以你要買這個股票除息呢
一定要特別避開
要避開那個除息當天表現不大好了
東元表現不大好
那你要買呢 就要找當天表現比較好的
除息當天表現比較好的
那這些都有
都有統計啦
都有統計喔 所以各位你可以看一下統計的狀況
統計狀況 看他之前表現好不好
那6月10校各位已經過了
6月10校最後一天了
明天最後一天了
欸?明天6月10校
6月18號沒有
6月22號這幾個
欸 東洋
喔 最近的表現都不好
除息當天的表現都不好
各位你要記得看這個
當日操作的報酬統計啊
喔 這邊會有
除息的狀況
喔 欸
圍影還不錯
圍影的除息狀況還不錯
欸 圍影這個
這個除泉的
還不錯喔 可是這隻除息而已
這還沒有到除泉啦 還沒有到除泉
除泉那一天應該還不錯
所以各位可以看一下
這邊會有一些星星啊
星星數越多會越好
那更細的交易的細節呢
我們就留在
留在這個
除泉席客呢再跟各位講
除泉席客呢
台中跟高雄
結束了都滿場
然後呢剩台北
台北長還有位子嗎
我...我不知道
對 群光啦
我想到了
群光...一直想不到最近儲學遺的
群光各位看一下
有沒有
都爛嘛 有沒有
是不是都很爛
群光是不是都很爛
對不對
所以...之前表現爛
啊還是一樣
那群光呢
他是一個高股息ETF喜歡的股票嘛
有沒有
他是一個高股息ETF喜歡的股票
一除息完
就開始跌嘛
一除息完就開始跌
這種呢蠻常見的
在高股息的標的裡面常見
群光是高股息喜歡的標的
然後一除息完就跌
所以各位啊這個高股息的標的呢
你要特別的小心避開
你假如你的股票是高股息
我建議你
在除息前
把它賣掉
這講是喔
你的股票是高股息
然後呢你再看一下這個軟體
看一下這個軟體
歷年來呢表現都很爛
例如說群光
歷年來表現都很爛
每次除息都下跌
那你就在他除息前把它賣掉
不要拆下除息啦
你拆下除息沒用啊 你拿到利息
有用嗎
所以你看
141塊
你拿到利息才7塊141塊拿到利息才7塊 現在剩116你把141塊把它賣掉現在16買回來
還差了25塊
對不對
等同於你配息25塊
還不用繳稅
你假如沒賣
參加配息還要繳稅
還要繳稅
你把它賣掉了不參加配息
疊下來再買回來
下來 再買回來
還不用繳
還不用繳這個苦力所得嘛
對不對
所以高股息的標的呢
各位記得
高股息標的常常都有這種狀況
常常都有這種配完息之後呢
開始跌
配完息之後
大家就
大家不碰了嘛
這
那個頭戲不買了
頭戲每次都這樣
他買股票參與除選息
是為了拿來配息的
他不是為了賺價差的
我們都是想賺價差
那你假如你真的想要配息
你可以自己配給自己呀
你懂嗎
你把錢
拿去放在你的期貨戶頭
放在你的期貨戶頭
現在呢圍台呢
一口呢
是這個
一口呢你就放40萬
你放40萬等同於沒有開槓桿
因為4萬點嘛
4萬點乘以10
你放45萬
算45000點
45萬買一口圍台
然後呢 你要配給自己從裡面領
自己從裡面領
只要
你大概可以配個10%
按照期望來算
配個10%沒什麼問題
就這樣
文頁也有
各位你看
有沒有
喔 文頁3036
喔不
喔
不過文頁之前是
前兩年表現還好
今年表現特別差
哇 開盤直接開
開這個9%
這會太慘
喔
真的太慘了齁
好 所以這個高股息齁
高股息各位
標的記得要篩選一下
好啦
那我們
呃 在7月初呢 有全政的初階班的課
全政初階班的課
全政初階班一陣子就沒上了很多人想要弄清楚全政怎麼樣做交易開個全政初階班課那這次開課的時間比較近一點比較近一點 我們大概就是一個月開一次課
只是因為那個
呃 那個台北廠的初屆班課比較晚
所以大家可能覺得好像很近
那台中廠來看大概就是一個月一次
一個月一次
所以各位呢 這個全正初屆班
這個會教各位 如何用全正來交易
還有給各位看 全政陷阱在哪裡
陷阱在哪邊
欸來來來
來
這個在這裡呢
我們要特別講一下全政的陷阱
特別講一下全政陷阱
剛好趁著這時候呢跟各位講
我們來看一下 挑選全政小幫助
我們講一下全政陷阱
來
全政陷阱是這樣子
這個我們在課堂上有提到
但是今天在這個平台呢 我們也要講一下
這個全鎮陷阱在這裡
我把那個
篩選
來來來來
來 我們講一下權政陷阱
什麼陷阱呢
呃
權政呢 他有履約價跟行資比例
那跟各位講 履約價跟行資比例呢
在除權席的時候
除權席的時候呢 他必須得做調整
再講一次
履約價跟行資比例呢 在除權席的時候要做調整
然後呢 舉例來講 我們來看這個原副
原副這一檔
那原副這一檔呢
他的行私比例呢是1.006
他原本設計呢
他行私比例呢是1
再講一次喔
他原本設計他的行私比例是1
1喔
喔
他行私比例不會是
不會是那個
呃
不會是這個1.006
他設計行私比例是1
像這個原副這一檔0.3
302 他原本設計呢 應該就是0.3
那 你看這邊的數字有的後面都怪怪的23是什是什麼的那都是他原本設計呢可能就是1或是一個固定的數字
然後呢在除全息的時候
在除全息的時候
他必須要調整
因為除全息的時候
你股價會往下跌嘛
例如說配5塊
配10塊
你的股價隔天平盤價
就要少5塊少10塊
那麼為了公平起見
你的履約價呢 就必須要怎麼樣
往下調 因為你股價跌了嘛
履約價往下調
然後行使比例往上升
為了公平起見
這個履約價跟行使比例要做這樣的調動
這調整
因為這樣調整呢 你的權證呢
才不會莫名其妙的
它的價值就會往下跌
因為你假如沒有調的話
沒有調的話 股票一配息
参考這個除息差好就往下跌了嘛
除息差好就往下降了
例如說100塊配5塊
隔天就95塊嘛 就往下降
結果你沒有調
沒有調 那全證
全證不就是看股價95塊
全證的價格就往下跌了嘛
這不公平嘛 對不對
所以呢 他要把履業價呢 往下調
把行事比例往上調嘛 對不對
這樣各位聽懂了齁
再講一次 把履業價往下調
把行事比例往上調
那像這個行事比例呢
他往上調就變1.06
其實比例往上調呢 這個數字就會增加
增加
但是呢各位啊
那個
權政的行使比例啊 再講一次
權政行使比例 它是
最小 應該就講說
它只能到小數點後面上位
再講一次喔 權政行使比例
只能到小數點後面上位
就是在一般的股票裡面
只能到小一點後面上位
那 假如往上調的過程中
比較尖的
正常是喔
我是覺得
那個券商假如
假如覺得他
他要吃點投資人豆腐的話呢
很簡單啦
他就把行事比例定成0.001
因為呢
我行事比例定成0.001
然後他在調整中
假設我們多10%好了
0.001
然後你的行字比例要調整成
0.0011
要調整成0.0011嘛
多10%
各位不曉得能不能聽得懂
我把它寫出來
就是
原本0.001嘛
那調整之後呢會變成
0.0011嘛
那假如原本0.01的話
調整是變成0.011
那原本0.01呢
調整呢就變0.1
假設要多10%的話
他會這樣調
所以0.1變0.1 OK
0.001變0.01
這也OK
0.001變0.001
欸 這個4125路變成0.001
所以有條等於沒條
呵呵有沒有看到
厲害了 有條等於沒條
喔 來
所以呢 0.001
喜歡0.01的券商
各位就要記得
0.01的券商是誰
所以我們把期日比例
把它
由小到大排序啊
恭喜
統一
耶
我們統一的
這個全證
名列齁
名列期日比例
從小
從小排序開始
都全部都統一
怎麼都統一啦
哎呀
大家鼓掌
有沒有看到
流通比全部
在外流通還非常多啦
哎呀
大家特別喜歡統一啊
這個
特愛統一
造勢造的好
齁
期日比例0.001
啊
好啦 你們愛就愛啦
我是不愛啦
我是不愛
所以呢我那個
我篩選的時候
自動把它取消
我在不
好啦好啦
各位不用取消啦
反正你在看
那個行駛比例就0.01啦
厲害
喔
同一厲害
這個
喔
不只
行駛比例
要弄你
還可以在隱含播東西弄你
好不好
各種弄
喔
那個
微買隱含波通力
一律往下跌
各位流通比81%
隱含波通力長這樣
長這樣
欸
流通81%在我靠啊
啊這行私比例
那個微買隱含波通力一直跌
就是
它的回收價一直往下跌啦
有沒有看到
回收價一直往下跌
所以
行私比例已經
這樣子搞了
微買隱含波又這樣子搞
各種弄
呵呵呵呵
至少五年前小哥推薦喔五年不止五年的啦我以前推薦後來我都不推薦了後來我都不推薦了各位你看流通比大的喔
只要流通比大的你看他長這樣
流通比大的啦
來啦
不要說我誤會他好不好
我們一檔一檔看
唉呦這檔也算爛啦
也沒多好
欸
這個也是有疊啦
喔
反正你就記得看
這也是有疊啦
你就看他的圍滿眼波啦
真的蠻厲害的
台積電影韓波動力90
90挖哥啦
到底衝什麼鬼啊
台積電影韓波動力90
欸我們以前
剛
我剛開始叫全證小哥的時候
我們的台積電影韓波動力都是230欸
你看台積電影韓波動力90
人歷史隱藍波動率起碼才27
啊你卖到90
賣到90還可以這樣子
還可以隱藍波動率從左上到右下
剛賣的時候78現在剩62
這就是我們講的啦
張梅三明 不好意思
你買完之後 不好意思
你買完之後就開始拍謝了
開始拍謝了
不好意思 不好意思 隱藍波動率
我隱藍波動力沒有沒有沒有沒有在手的啦沒有在手的啦
哇你看以前賣60現在剩40啦
隱藍波動力在講的時候隱藍波動力的數字喔
數字越低啊
隱藍波動力的數字越低呢
這檔的全證價格越差
全證價格的
哇統一創辦人今天裡面三好一公道
這個喔?三好一公道?
真的三好一公道
我...我是看不見啦
我看不見啦
什麼人跟我講
你自己看同一個波動率好不好
都剩下這種
不要說我...不要說我針對他啦好不好
不要說我針對他
我來看一下
我們來看元大好了
我們看元大
元大 元大 元大 來
來 元大
你叫白白 那個白白嗎
47的白白
啊44的白白 對不對啊45嗎 對不對 這正常嗎欸 歷史27你賣45 OK啊歷史47 歷史27你賣45可以嗎
就是你可以這樣想
那個你的批發價27啊你賣45塊我覺得OK嘛
結果現在統一是你的批發價27
然後呢 你賣90幾
賣90幾就算了 回收價一直往下掉
喔 還可以啊 已經往下掉了
難怪你頭一不找出了 你嚇到垂花也不會去
你怎麼都要吃
垂花也不會去
所以各位 你要買全鎮齁
一定要怎麼樣 一定要看一下
看一下喔 這裡喔
欸 你一定要看這個喔
這個一定要批批喔
微買影坡要平平的喔
平平的喔 好不好
各位啊 不要買到微買影坡一路往下掉的喔
這種特別的券商我們一定要特別講出來
這維白眼涵波動律一路往下跌
一路往下跌 我看到
就是你看錯時跌很慘
然後看對時不會賺 或是賺很少
就是這樣
他就是各種弄各種稿
然後呢各種弄各種稿
流通比在外非常高
嘿
奇怪了
各種論還可以流通比在外這麼高
我實在不知道投資人在抵什麼
不知道他抵什麼
好啦
那個
大家想買就買
你愛買你就買
我是買可以買
我買可以買
你想買你就買啦
你開心你就買就好了
反正你記得買權政不要遇到這一種
好啦
我們今天呢
又得罪人了
搞不好又要被修理了
所以就這樣
好
來 直播快展 你先直播快展
這個
超直播一下 購買全萬元監控當中神器
限制家五九折
當中神器五九折 全方位也五九折
有需要籌碼可以信任在這邊
好 我們今天的直播差不多講到這邊了
差不多講到這邊了 我要準備來錄PP了
喔
準備
來錄PP
微白眼波有可能上什麼啊 有可能啊
就是被投資人追告嘛 有可能好喜歡今天直播歡迎按讚訂閱 留言關心得喔吉米娃娃跟軟體現場QA時間欸 沒時間QA啦
好啦
當神器不會用怎麼辦
都有那個
那個買軟體喔
我裡面都有教學
各位呢 你去看一下教學
看一下教學
當神器很好用的啦
我都靠當神器做當衝的啊
喔 這邊
欸來來
你看一下喔 你看我的那個
我們出國在外用當沖神器做當沖
出國在外特別喜歡PO
對上單
平常沒那麼愛PO
出國在外特別喜歡PO
因為出國在外就用當沖神器做啊
這邊很多都是當沖神器
欸你現在看喔
這個是
你看這邊是500
賺500多萬
這很多歷程啊
這個我們群
群...團圓很多歷程
團圓很多歷程
歷程期...歷程期...一堆歷程
然後這邊很多都是靠down層去做的啦
這做的都是靠down層去
好
同樣有沒有好...同樣好抽啊
嗯...也是有的啦 各位自己看啦
是不是嫌我...得罪的不夠多啊
處置的權政比較難找 處置的權政比較難找
喔 因為那個
還是用一樣方向找X-米去找
立成信物出完了 還沒出完
還沒出完
出掉大半了 還沒出完
喔
當成績影片看不懂
呃 你去看當中親手全攻略
那個會更 更仔細
就是會教你怎麼挑股票
怎麼抓轉折這樣
好啦 最後呢 我們來抽獎
抽獎之後我就要結束了
錯啦
除了幾行情 全攻列 台北堂 幾號上課
呃 幾號上課 各位來抽一下
抽一下齁
抽一下
線上亂數產生器
好 我們抽一下
我們抽一下
抽
喔好 今天是15號到30號啦
好 以上
這個
我們今天直播要結束啦
各位呢 我們今天直播呢 最後有
有這娃娃抽獎 看你喜歡哪一個
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕